the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
that's a part of their subject part of
deep learning as we get there and it's
probably a good topic for the day before
spring break because lots of you will
have seen of course you will have seen
the sample mean the average of the of
the data so we we have and you'll know
about the expected mean let me complete
that what's the expected mean so this is
the expectation of the value X where we
get x 1 with probability P 1 belong to X
n with probability P n so we just want
to say what's our average out output
average outcome and we weight it by
their probabilities so it's P 1 X 1 plus
along plus P n X n so that's the
expected value of x do you comfortable
with that symbol e because that's like
everywhere it gives a handy shorthand
for example the variance is the expected
value of what
the variance is an expected value based
on these probabilities of the square of
the distance so everybody remembers it's
involves square and it's the distance
from the mean from so I'm let me call
this state M maybe just to have a
smaller letter but I could put so it's
the distance from the mean minus M it's
the expected value the average value of
X minus M Squared and in general of
course the expected this covariance
matrix I could express with that any
notation but let me just stretch it as
far as what would be the expected value
of any function of X well we've got n
possible outputs x1 to xn we look at f
of x1 up to f of xn
we wait those by the probabilities that
they happen so this would be let me make
just a little corner for this e letter
so this would be the probability that
that is f of x1 times the value of the
value F at x1 so this is the
contribution from the x1 possibility and
now we include them all so it'll be F
output f of X ends with probability PN
and if that f of X is X minus M squared
then we get what we expect and let me
remember that so I just want to keep
going with variance so it's the sum it's
the first probability times the first
output minus the mean squared
the last probability times that last
output xn minus M Squared
and everybody should know a second
expression the second way to do that cut
the sum it's just if I just write out
those squares and combine them a little
differently I get a second expression
which is really useful often a little
faster to compute so can I just do that
so that's that's X 1 squared minus 2 X 1
M 1 plus M 1 squared right and then save
me here pn x xn squared minus 2 xn n
plus M Squared good with it
sorry plus n oh sorry
oh no I mean am i oh it's just a name
correct thank you thank you just too
damn good ok can we take that sum so I
get P 1 X 1 squared if I take these the
first guys so I've accounted for this
and this now I'll take minus 2 P 1 X 1 M
so P 1 X 1 M plus P n X ends M
I'm just writing it all out and I'm
gonna recombine it so now I have P 1 M
squared plus P 2 m squared plus P n m
squared so what do I have from the P 1 M
Squared all the way up to P n M Squared
are you with me so M Squared is a Frick
is in every term so I'm gonna have an M
Squared and what's it multiplied by P 1
here P 2 here P n here I add those up
and I get 1 so that's it
ok and now I'll just simplify this thing
so this is really the expected value of
what what am i seeing in this in this
term the about the expected value of x
squared right
different from the expected value of X
minus M Squared of course this is just
the first term from here but now what do
I get for this second term well the
point is that M comes out so this is
minus and M and a 2 and what it what do
I have left so I've used up the M I've
used up the 2 P 1 X 1 plus P and X n
what's that everybody should just pay
attention to this trivial I mean we're
just doing high school algebra here but
but P 1 X 1 up to P and X n is M so I
have another M M Squared there and I've
a plus M Squared
from the end so you see that it is
another expression the expected value of
x squared minus M Squared just algebra
that that is the same as this so that if
you happen to have a handy way to
compute
the expected value of x squared you
would just subtract M squared and you'd
have the same as this yeah it's just
algebra okay
can i let's let's go a little deeper
with something here if I can find it
there are two great inequalities in
statistics and the first one is due to
Markov and I don't know if you know
Markov inequality it it comes out easily
in fact too easily I like I'm kind of
happy with the discussion in this is now
I'm jumped to section five over the book
so I'll need to post section 5 which is
probability and statistics and you'll
see this Markov inequality so it just
involves this stuff so that's why I'll
go do it now
Markov inequality he was a great Russian
mathematician or probably about 1900 and
we will see Markov chains and Markov
processes that's beautiful linear
algebra but this little inequality is
not matrices it's just playing with
these but and it applies to two
non-negative events so I'm gonna win
shall I say applies when all the X all
the outputs are greater equal zero so
it's going to be a it's gonna I'm gonna
use that fact so it doesn't apply to to
something like Gaussian because they're
Gaussian the outputs go all the way from
minus infinity to and
finiti it does apply to a lot of
important ones and simple one so I'm
just saying let's suppose I would give
the proof for this finite probability
and there'd be a similar proof similar
discussion everywhere here
for continuous probability so what does
Markov say let me be sure I get it right
because I'm not a pro at this it it's
natural to want to estimate the
probability that X is greater equals
some number a get some idea what's the
probability of X being greater equal a
so what do we know there's a certainly a
number between 0 & 1 that number is
going to get smaller as a increases
because we're going to be asking for
more if if if I take a to be say twice
the mean well yeah suppose I take a to
be twice the mean what what so can I
estimate what that probability could be
and that's what Markov has done he says
the probability of that is at least at
most sorry
see I used to have an eraser at least
sorry at most yes got it is less or
equal to the mean x-bar is another way
to write the mean divided by a and this
is this is the mean over a or it's the
expected value of x over a we could see
any of those
notations okay and as we expect as a
increases the probability this this
number goes down the probability goes
down of exceeding a so that's a pretty
simple estimate to get this probability
just in terms of the number a which has
to come in because it's part of the
question and the me X okay so let me
take an example as a equals three okay
so I'm going to try I'm gonna just for
example suppose a was three I want to
show that the probability of X X being
greater than or equal to three yeah okay
so let's we we don't know we don't have
many facts to work with so if we write
those down we should see the reason okay
so I know that the mean is a of X so
let's see I'm am I gonna take yeah I'm
gonna for example let's take the mean to
be one okay so I'm gonna imagine that
the mean is one and that I'm asking for
what's the chance that X will be bigger
than three and I'll get an estimate of
one-third so I'm trying to show to show
the probability of X greater equal three
is less or equal to the mean I'm saying
is one a is three so there's less or
equal 1/3 now why is that true that's
what I have to show okay I think is that
if I write down what I know I'll see it
okay
all right so let me let me just raise
that a little so that I have a room to
write so what do I know I know the
definition of the meat so I know that X
1 times P 1 plus X 2 P 2 plus X 3 P 3
allow me to get carried away here X 5 p
5 say is is what so what I've written
down there is the mean and I'm assuming
that to be 1 so this is the fact that I
know is 1 and what is it that I want to
prove I want to know the probability of
being greater equals 3 so what's the
probability that the result will be
greater equal 3 it's P 3 so this this is
saying that P 3 plus P for those this is
these are the probabilities these are
the different ways that I might be
greater equals 3 and I'm claiming that
that's less or equal 1/3 what I liked
about this elementary approach is that
I've stated these facts these
probability assumptions and and and
conclusions directly in terms of numbers
so I just want to show that if this is
true then that's true
oh let's see I guess I'm thinking that
the I'm sorry I even took a more special
case I'm taking the case where x1 is 1 X
2 is 2 X 3 is 3 X 4 is 4 and X 5 is 5 so
that satisfies satisfies my condition
that the the outputs 1 2 3 4 or 5 are
all Markov Markov only applies when
they're all greater equals 0 so I had to
take a so I'm just imagining this
special case where the possible outputs
are 1 2 3 4 5 their probabilities are P
1 P 2 P 3 P 4 P 5 the mean is 1 and what
I want to show is that the probability
of being greater than 3 is less or equal
1/3 and can you put together these two
can you conclude given this we want to
conclude that let me just step back a
minute
so we're what do we know here we know
this the first line and we want to prove
the second line we know one more thing
all the probabilities well we know the
probabilities add to 1 and we know
they're all greater equals 0 so let me
put those facts in here too
we know that P 1 plus P 2 plus P 3 plus
B 4 plus B 5 is 1 that we know and we
also know that all the peas are greater
than or equal to 0 okay okay
so here we go I think my my idea is this
is this is looking at three times P 3
plus B 4 + P 5 so I'm going to take 3 P
3 plus 3 P 4 away from this so this will
say P 1 plus 2 P 2 plus 3 of piece reef
plus P 4 plus P 5 I'm just picking out 3
of those guys
plus I have one more P 4 to account for
and two more P 5 gives one okay good now
this is what I'm trying to prove so that
is here I'm trying to prove that this
thing is what am I trying to prove about
that number and you're sorry I'm talking
a lot but now I've really come to the
point what what is Markov telling me
about that number that's that is less or
equal to thanks okay I'm trying to prove
that this is less or equal one that's
what Markov tells me but suppose it was
greater than one
do you see the problem you see why it
can't be greater than one because why
all the other terms are greater equals
zero
probabilities are greater or equal zero
these are all greater equal zero and the
total thing adds to one so that this
piece has to be lesser equal the one
that's right that's it yeah so a lot of
talking there simple idea and you'll see
the exactly this example written down in
notes okay and then you'll see a more
conventional proof of Markov inequality
by taking any simple inequality steps
but there's somehow more mysterious for
me this was explicit
okay so that's Markov chebychev is the
other great russian probable list of the
time and he gets his his inequality so
there are the two there's markov
inequality let me write it down again
what it was here was markov inequality
on the barkoff assumption chebychev
doesn't make that assumption
so now no no assumption that the outputs
are equals it doesn't come in okay now
what is chebychev trying to estimate
okay
let's move to chebychev and that's the
last guy
so he Timmy Chavez into it interested in
the probability probability that X minus
the mean M can I use that for me is
probably greater or equal to a the
probability of being sort of a distance
a away from the meet so again as they
increases I'm asking more I'm asking it
to be further away from the mean and the
probability will drop and then the
question is can we estimate this so this
is a different estimate but it's similar
similar question and what's chubby
Jeff's answer for this so this is the
probability of this I have to put up big
that's all one grit one mouthful the
probability of being that this X minus M
is greater equal to a okay and again
we're gonna have is less or equal to
Sigma squared now comes in over a square
so that's Chevy cheff and I just take
time today to do these two because
they're they involve analysis there
there are basic tools as sort of the
first thing you think of if you're
trying to estimate a probability does it
fit Markov and it only Markov only
applies so I'll put only applies when
the X's are all greater or equal zero
here does it fit chebychev and now we're
taking absolute values so we're not
concerned about the size of X
and we're taking the distance from em so
we're obviously in the world of
variances we're distances from em okay
and and the proof of chebychev is comes
directly from Markov so so why we're
going to apply Markov so good thing that
Markov came first - now let me just say
this right - a - a - a new let me call
it Y this will be a new output and it
will be X minus M Squared so that's if I
of course with the same probability so
why I is x i- m the mean squared and the
same probabilities same probabilities P
okay so I guess if I'm going to apply
I'm just going to take that it takes a
wise here instead of the X's here so and
then apply Markov so what is X bar so if
I want to apply Markov I have to figure
out the mean of X over here I have to
figure out the mean of Y what is the
mean of Y the mean value the sum of
probabilities x wise
you're supposed to recognize it this is
the sum of probabilities and my y's are
the x i minus the mean squared so this
is the mean for this this this y thing
that I've brought in has that formula
and we recognize what that quantity is
that is that Sigma squared Sigma squared
for the original X's so that's just
that's great so the mean is Sigma is the
old Sigma square those are exclamation
marks okay so then I do you see that now
Markov is looking like or chebychev is
looking like Markov because here over
here will be the X now I want the
expected value of y over let's see yep
so the expected Y is going to be that
and now what do I have to divide by I
want to know probabilities of something
being bigger of this thing being bigger
than a but now I'm looking at the Y's so
the probability of if X minus M is
greater than or equal to a then X minus
X I minus M Squared is greater equal a
squared so so I my my a over here for X
is now turning in this problem where I'm
looking a probability greater equal a
but squaring it this the is the a
squared
so that's Markov applied to Y here's
Markov applied to X and X had to be
greater equals zero
so over here chebychev took a Y which
was greater equals zero then just
applied Markov and recognized that what
that the mean was of his variable X my
my X minus M Squared was exactly Sigma
squared and it fell out so again here is
a very simple proof for Markov and then
everybody agrees that chebychev follows
right away from Markov ok so those are
two basic inequalities now the other
topic that I wanted to to deal with was
covariance covariance matrix you have to
get like comfortable or what is that
what's the covariance okay
[Applause]
so covariance covariance matrix and it
will be M by M when I have M M sort of
experiments M at once let me take a me
put the two you you'll see everything
for m equal to two so it's a we're
expecting to get a two by two matrix and
what are we starting with we start we're
doing two experiments at once so we have
two outputs two outputs an X and the y
so the X's are the outputs from the X
experiment the Y's are the output from
the from a second experiment we're
flipping two coins so let's take that
example two coins coin one gets zero or
one with people probability 1/2 coin to
0 or 1 with probability 1/2 so they're
fair coins but what I haven't said is
are there is there a connection between
the output this is the X this is the Y
is if I glue the coins together then the
two outputs are the same I think this
for me this is a model question that
brings out the main point of covariance
if I flip two coins separately quite
independently then there's no
[Music]
I can't I don't know more about why from
knowing X if I know the answer to one
flip it doesn't tell me anything about
the second if they're independent
uncorrelated but if the two coins are
glued together then heads so come up for
both coins
it'll be I'll only have two
possibilities that'll be heads heads or
tails tails let me let me write down
that there was two different scenarios
so unglued I never expected to write
that word in a math class and what am I
going to write down I'm going to write
down a matrix with heads tails for coin
1 and heads and tails for coin 2 so the
possibilities are coin one gets heads
and point two gets heads what's the
probability of that this is the unglued
case so I'm gonna create a little
probability matrix of joint
probabilities that's really the key word
that you yeah that I'm discussing here
joint probabilities so let's complete
that matrix so I have unglued coins
independent coins I flip them both what
what is the chances of getting heads on
both 1/4 what are the chances of what do
I put in here
this means heads on the first coin and
tails on the second Queen and the
probability of that is 1/4 and 1/4 here
and 1/4 here so I've there four
possibilities which I put into a 2x2
matrix instead of a long vector my two
four possibilities are heads heads has
heads tails tails heads and tails tails
and they have equal
probability 1/4 but now if they're glued
heads and tails on the first coin heads
and tails on the second on the first
coin heads and tails on the second coin
okay now what do I put in there so the
two coins are glued together what is the
chance that they both come up heads what
half right one half if one comes up
heads
the other one is glued to it it will
also what what's the probability of
heads tails heads on one tails on the
other is of course zero thanks
and here's 0 and here 1/2 so what I've
created are those 2 possible plus 2
different setups two different scenarios
unglued and glued and in this one we
have but each each experimental setup
has its matrix of joint probabilities
that's that's the thing that there are
four numbers here four numbers we have
all possibilities we have any any
possible X and at the same time any
possible Y so suppose we had suppose we
were running three experiments and we
had well so what would be the what would
be the situation if I was running three
experiments with an independent three
independent fair coins so I'd have I'd
be in this unglued picture but I would
have three different experiments that
I'm running then what what's what would
be what would I be looking at them just
the whole idea is to see what is this
like joint probability so suppose I have
three
coin unglue then I want to know like
some probability of getting heads on the
first heads on the second heads on the
third will be what just to give me that
number what will be the probability of
that all three of them independently
come up heads one eight okay but now my
question is so what do I have then I
have probability of heads of say tails
heads heads I've got three indices here
eventually down to probability of tails
tails tails everybody sees at the end of
the numbers are going to be 1/8 but
what's the what's where those fit in
they don't fit in a matrix because I've
got three indices here so I guess what
we're seeing I sort of realized today
we're seeing for the first time a tensor
a tensor is a three-way structure
three-way matrix you could say so we
have I guess I think of the of this
instead of a square like that an
ordinary matrix I have to think of cube
right I have a cube with with with two
rows two columns and to what Evers
layers somebody might say layers for
that do you see that the the matrix has
become
a three-way thing a tenser and the
entries in that tenser so it's two by
two by two that instead of M by n for a
matrix I have to give you the number of
rows and number of columns and the
number of layers going into the board so
rows going one way you know
columns rows and then layers are going
deep so I will that it will have a ten
trees and of course in this simple case
each will be one eight in this in that
in that unglue totally independent way
but but then you can imagine some
dependence say well if I so what would
happen if I glued coins one and three I
would still have a tensor still have a
two by two by two tensor of all the
possibilities now but some of those are
going to have probability zero the joint
probability if I've glued coin one to
coin three then the probability of
jointly seeing heads on one whatever on
two tails on three will be zero right
because that can't happen if I've glued
coins one and three so I'll have eight
entries in here in the this is the
unglued case and then I could have the
case where two coins are glue and as I
say I think the the I would have four
I'd have one quarter four times probably
and then if I had any spare glue I glue
all three coins I flip that stuck
together thing and I never get heads
tails heads right only possibilities I
get our heads heads heads and tails
tails tails because they're glued
together so what would be the situation
for three coins ooh what will be the
entries in the joint in the matrix of
joint probabilities what will be the
joint probabilities so they joint the
probability of heads heads heads I've
seen heads from all three will be 1/2
1/2 because I'm flipping this heavy mix
of three coins together I get 1/2 twice
okay actually I this is a good
introduction to tensors in a way because
the the first step in understanding
tensors is to think of 3-way matrices
think of 3-way things what you know we
just haven't done that and now we have
to do it and of course for where or
anyway tensors are now understood okay
so this these are tensors with very
special simple things okay so now I have
to say what is the covariance matrix but
what's the covariance matrix so now I'm
ready for that and I'll put it here
that's the final topic
so the covariance matrix so I'm saying
matrix because I'm just gonna have yeah
the covariance matrix yeah it's going to
be two by two or four two coins so it is
a matrix for three coins it will be
three by three but it is a matrix okay
so what how is it defined and what am I
going to call it I think I'll call it V
for four because it really the key ideas
variance covariance is is telling us
that we're also interested in the
committee the joint outcome an x and a y
okay so what so it's a variance so I'm
going to add up over all possible I and
J over all sorry all possible outcomes
yeah all possible X I and YJ so I'm
running the six these two experiments at
the same time from experiment one the
outputs and X from experiment to the
outputs of Y then what is P I J what
does that symbol mean that's that's the
guy in our 2x2 matrix like that one or
that one
depending on the gluing or not gluing so
P IJ this is let me say what it is this
is this probability that X
is X I and the second output that this
is YJ and let me give me a second
example to keep in mind suppose I'm
looking at age and height so suppose X
is the age of the of the sample the
person and Y is the height then I want
to I want to know so what fraction have
a certain age and a certain height it's
every I I'm looking at every pair age
and height age 11 height four feet age
12 height five feet age 11 height four
five feet each combination so pIJ is the
probability that these will both happen
both so what could you just I I'm gonna
add more to it here but but that joint
probability is really important so I'm
gonna ask you more about that suppose
that I take these P I J's and that I add
up P 1 J plus P 2 J plus P 3 J in other
words I sum the pIJ x' over I so I'm
looking at a row row I of my matrix so
what just saw let me ask the question if
I maybe I have to put it somewhere else
what is what what means what's the
meaning of the sum of P IJ over the eyes
what does that quantity look like so
that's a probability pIJ is the
probability of getting a certain I on a
certain J but now I'm including
all the eyes so what am i seeing there
what PJ
thanks PJ this is he J that's the
probability of seeing J in the second
guy because I had to see something if I
see J in the second one I I'm allowed to
see anything here in the first one but
I'm adding those all up so that's the
point
those would be called the marginals in
my matrices I would be adding up along a
row or adding up down a column those are
called the marginal of the joint
probabilities so the marginals would be
the individual probabilities P I and PJ
in the case of two experiments going on
at the same time yeah just like new
ideas everything today has been sort of
straightforward but it's different okay
now I'm going to complete the definition
of this covariance matrix so it's going
to be it I want to have a square so it's
going to be and and it should be this is
pretty X and the mean of x mean one I
could call it a mean of x and y the
distance from the mean of Y times so
it's going to be column times a row same
X minus the mean of X Y minus the mean
of Y X I Y J
so can can you look at this formula so
this is with two two experiments two
experiments two coins to experiment I
get a 2 by 2 matrix everybody sees that
a column times a row 2 by 2 matrix and
let's just see what would be the one one
entry in that matrix what what will in
this is the covariance matrix so what is
the one one entry in that matrix so the
one one entry is coming from that times
that which is that thing squared times
all the P IJ's add them up what do you
think I get for that I get the variance
of the X experiment the standard
variance of the X experiment so V I have
to tell you what V is now there V this
is V 2 by 2 matrix up here I get the
variance of the X experiment what do I
get down here the variance of the Y
experiment by itself because it's wise x
wise that give me the to to entry so
this is just Sigma Y squared Sigma Y
square ok but the novelty is the 1/2 and
it'll be symmetric so it's a symmetric
matrix so this is V transpose I just we
have to see here so I've p IJ times the
distance of this guy times this guy
that's what's going to show up in the
1/2 position it'll be in row 1 that'll
be in column 2 it's the X it's the
distances so so what will it be in the
case of unglued coins independent coins
0 I mean I was just feeling like 0 I
haven't done the computation
but I know that when I have independent
experiments then this covariance which
everybody would write as Sigma X Y and
it's the same here it's symmetric Sigma
YX if you like so that those those
subscripts are telling me that the sum
of the peas joint probabilities times
the distance of X from its mean the
distance of Y from its mean added up
over all the possibilities so the case
of unglued coins in case of independent
ones in that case those are 0 may be
worth just writing that out you would
get 0 so you have a diagonal matrix the
diagonal matrix is just the very
separate variances because that's all
the two independent experiments are
independent so all you can really expect
to information is Sigma x squared and
Sigma Y squared but if the two coins are
glued together then what if the two
coins are glued together well let me
just say cuz time is up
this matrix will be singular if the two
coins were glued together this would be
the determinant would be 0 here the
Sigma XY in the glued case would be
squared would would be the same as Sigma
x squared Sigma Y square actually we're
probably getting all these 1 quarters
and and that would make sense so the the
case of a so we just end with this
statement this matrix is positive
semi-definite always positive semi
definite always because it's column
times row we know that's positive semi
definite and it's multiplied by numbers
greater equals 0 so it's a combination
of Rank 1 positive semi definite so it's
positive
semi-definite or positive definite it's
certainly positive definite in the
independent case when it's diagonal and
totally dependent case when the coins
are completely stuck together that will
be the semi definite case when these
entries would all be the same actually
so so that's a first look at covariance
matrices a first it brought in tensors
it brought in joint probabilities it
brought in column times row
it kept symmetry band we recognized
positive definite or positive semi
definite
so in between coins that were partly
glued partly independent but not
completely independent experiments then
this number would be smaller the
determinant would be this wouldn't be
zero but it would be smaller than these
numbers yeah okay
we're run four minutes over you're very
kind to say so have a wonderful break
and I'll see you a week from Monday good
thanks